TYRA: The 13 finalists
from America's Next Top Model
are taking the competition
to terrifying new levels.
Facing raging bulls,
shaky ground, and...
MODELS: Fabio.
TYRA: Three girls
have survived it all.
And tonight,
one of them will be named
America's Next Top Model.
Will it be Eugena,
the sassy siren
from Southern California?
JAY: You don't like
the last season
of America's Next
Top Model girls.
They're boring. It just seems
like they're really generic.
TYRA: But for all
of her boasting,
Eugena started out
flat in front of the camera.
It was like you were asleep with
your eyes open on the shoot.
After two separate weeks
in the bottom two,
Eugena started showing
some life in her eyes.
WOMAN: I was looking at it
like, "Who is this girl?
Why all of a sudden does
she have passion in her eyes?"
TYRA: But the judges
began to doubt.
JANICE: Is this something
that you have passion for?
TYRA: Whether they were
still on the prize.
Yes, it is.
TYRA:
Can Eugena finally muster up
top model attitude
and a flawless photo
when it matters most?
Or will I be Melrose,
the hyper-confident
clothing designer
from San Francisco.
JAY: Can you name top
fashion designers?
Chanel, Derek Lam,
Proenza Schouler, Zac Posen.
TYRA: She won the first
challenge.
- Melrose.
- Aah!
TYRA: But took her Diva
for the Day prize too seriously.
Oh, honey, I've been ready
for, like, six hours.
Really?
The attitude right now,
don't slow for shoots.
TYRA: The results brought
her to her knees.
Melrose made the most
of her second chance
winning challenges...
- Melrose.
- Yay.
TYRA: And delivering
gorgeous photos.
NIGEL: Melrose has certainly
risen in the ranks.
TYRA: While that competitive
fire impressed the judges,
it burned some
of her roommates.
You piss people off.
Maybe there's just a part
of me you don't like.
TYRA: Tonight, this
perfectionist has to handle
the pressure and prove
that there's a soft side
under that fierce facade.
Aah!
TYRA:
Or will it be CariDee,
the stunner from North Dakota
with the big personality
and a powerful
motivation to succeed.
Three months ago I had a skin
disease that covered 70%
- of my body called psoriasis.
- Oh, really?
It's a really emotional thing.
Because I always wanted
to model, and I
always got turned down.
TYRA: With her
psoriasis behind her,
CariDee's carefree
sense of humor
doubled over
into her photo shoots.
NIGEL: You haven't allowed
the fact you have
an elephant nose
inhibit you at all.
TYRA: This energy served
her well in the challenges
and at the panel.
I smell what you're
stepping in.
TYRA: Until she took
it one step too far
and insulted Nigel.
TYRA: And suddenly
her biggest strength
became her biggest weakness.
We don't want someone
going out representing
America's Next Top Model
who doesn't act with class,
dignity, and respect.
TYRA: Can CariDee reign
in her wild personality
before it spirals out
of control?
Find out tonight
who will be
America's Next Top Model?
( music playing )
♪ You want to be on top? ♪
♪ Wanna be on top? ♪
♪ It's time to make it hot ♪
♪ You know that we don't stop ♪
♪ And when you get it hot ♪
♪ You got to be on top ♪
♪ Na na na na na na,
na na na na ♪
♪ You wanna be on top? ♪
♪ Na na na na na na,
na na na na ♪
♪ You wanna be on top? ♪
♪ Na na na na na na,
na na na na ♪
♪ You wanna be on top? ♪
( music playing )
Hello.
ALL: Hey!
You're my final three girls!
Whoo!
JAY: Today you girls are gonna
be doing a TV commercial
and print ad for CoverGirl
Outlast Double LipShine.
- Oh, my God!
- Whoo!
CARIDEE: I mean,
it's every girl's dream to do
a CoverGirl commercial
and a CoverGirl photo shoot,
that is unreal.
JAY: I'm gonna direct
your commercial.
It's really pretty.
JAY: And Jim De Yonker
is gonna be your photographer.
Whoever wins
America's Next Top Model
has this ad we shoot today
in a national magazine.
How can we do this without
having a real CoverGirl
here today
to help coach you girls?
America's Next Top Model
winner, Danielle.
- Y'all look cute.
- Whoo!
JAY: But I hear that
I now have to call you Dani,
your agency
has renamed your name.
That's right,
no more Danielle, it's Dani.
I'm the newest
CoverGirl as well
as the newest top model,
and I know today you all
are doing your photo shoot
and commercial for the
newest product with CoverGirl.
Always remember
that you're a role model now.
So make good decisions,
good choices,
and have fun with
everything that you do.
And stay grounded
and level-headed like this girl.
I don't need anymore divas
walking around.
DANI: Yeah.
( music playing )
CARIDEE: I've studied my lines
but I'm not trying to study
them too hard because
then you'll over-think it.
Wish your lip gloss could
party all night?
Finally,
color that gets it right.
God, no.
You gotta stop looking.
CARIDEE: Stop listening
to me then, ho.
Excuse me?
EUGENA:
Melrose needs to be perfect,
and she doesn't care
about people,
she doesn't care about
anyone else's feelings.
She's just worried about herself
and how well she's gonna do
in this competition.
See, I'm over-thinking.
Melrose got me
all freaked out, man.
She just keeps going and going.
EUGENA: CariDee and I
want it to be us in the top two.
We don't want Melrose to win
just because
we feel that she's fake.
- You look good.
- CARIDEE: Thanks.
DANI: Y'all don't seem
nervous at all.
It gets to that point
to where it's like,
"Okay, another photo shoot,
another..."
DANI: I'm excited.
I'm excited, yeah.
MELROSE:
I know how much I want this,
and I know how long I've
wanted something like this.
And I haven't
heard it once from Eugena.
CoverGirls are all
about being friendly
and beautiful
and the girl next door.
No big toothy grins
and--Yeah, exactly.
And action.
New CoverGirl--
New CoverGirl Outlast Shine.
New ( makes sound )
New CoverGirl Outlast.
The pressure of the
competition was in my head.
You think about Tyra,
you think about Jay,
you know, in the other
room looking at you.
Outlast Double LipShine.
JAY: Don't over-think it,
CariDee.
- Just be you.
- CARIDEE: I'm trying.
I was so nervous watching her,
but she loosened up.
CARIDEE:
I just got to stop thinking.
I'm a blonde,
it's not working out.
JAY: My problem
with CariDee though
is when you let that boat go,
it just goes crazy
all over the place.
Bl-bl-bl-blah.
♪ Outlast Double LipShine ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
It's hard to pull back
on the reigns with CariDee.
New CoverGirl
Outlast Double LipShine.
It's the first lasting
shine gloss
that goes for ten hours.
That's five times
longer than lip gloss.
Slip on the color,
slick on the shine.
- JAY: Great job. Cut.
- Whoa.
JAY: You were so much
more yourself there.
Thank you, guys.
You really want to kind
of sell the product
without coming across
like used car salesman.
- Mm-hmm.
- Action.
Slip on the color,
slick on the shine.
CoverGirl Outlast
Double LipShine.
JAY: Okay. Cut.
That was stiff.
And action.
Wish your lip gloss
could party all night?
JAY: Eugena started off
really flat and boring.
Eugena, who are you talking to?
- My girlfriend.
- Really?
- That's how you talk to them?
- No.
I think I have to
remember what the judges
had been telling me
this whole time.
I need to smile more
and be more open.
To work on my personality.
And action.
Dance, dine, have a "feasta,"
your old lip gloss?
Hasta la vista.
I was holding my breath.
That was so good.
- Okay.
- Great. Thanks.
There is just so much
riding on this--no.
Eugena doesn't get nervous.
JAY: Action.
Slip on that color
and slick on that shine.
And you'll be lasting shiny
a very long time.
JAY: Cut. "And you'll
be shining a very long time."
Get the lines right, Melrose.
- JAY: It's not shiny, shining.
- Shining.
Action.
Slick that color on
and slip on that shine.
- Cut.
- Oh, nerves get out of my body.
JAY: Melrose is
the ultimate perfectionist.
- Don't over-think it.
- MELROSE: Yeah.
Don't panic through it.
New CoverGirl Outlast
Double LipShine.
Okay. Cut.
Don't punch that too much.
New CoverGirl Outlast...
Double LipShine!
I'm a cheerleader.
JAY: That's awful.
Talk--Remember,
talk to somebody.
We have time for one more.
Oh, I want a hundred more.
Bring real energy to it.
Not that fake energy.
Action.
Finally,
color that gets it right.
New CoverGirl Outlast
Double LipShine.
JAY: Good. All right.
You can come out of there,
Melrose. You're done.
You are done.
You're going to hell.
So just leave this all in here.
- MELROSE: Okay.
- And give me a serving photo.
( crying ) I couldn't even say
the product name right.
No?
It's not. It's everything.
It's hard hearing hard comments,
because it feels
like if I make one mistake,
I'm out of here.
I couldn't even
say the product name right.
No?
- Yes.
- JAY: Melrose needs to learn
how to let it go
and to stop self-evaluating.
JIM: Looks like your lips are
shaking a little bit.
- MELROSE: They are.
- Are you okay?
- MELROSE: I'm nervous.
- Just let it be natural.
JIM: Melrose,
she was thinking too much.
You could tell
her mind was just like,
"I need to do this, this,
this, this." Very technical.
Need to be beautiful,
calm, collected.
MELROSE: This is
the most important shoot,
and I'm like, "Okay,
You have to perform now."
JIM: Good. Good reset.
( music playing )
Chin down a little bit.
Okay. All right.
MELROSE: I'm happy
overall that
I went, I performed,
and I got the job done.
JIM: We're gonna
get some good beauty shots.
Oh, yeah.
I love the camera.
I'm just trying
to look really blissful,
not, you know, sexy,
not powering,
just, oh, relaxed.
- Good job.
- Thank you.
Yeah, thank you.
The shot is all about the face.
- EUGENA: Okay.
- And your lips.
EUGENA: I'm going
into this photo shoot making
sure that my eyes aren't dead.
I don't want Tyra Banks
telling me
that I have dead eyes anymore.
Nice. More front. Yeah.
There you go.
Good luck.
You can tell my wife.
EUGENA: Now all we have
to do is our pickup shots
of the commercial, and we'll
be done for the day.
- Action.
- New from easy...
- Breezy.
- Beautiful.
ALL: CoverGirl!
EUGENA: We fall onto this couch,
and we start laughing
and joking
like we're best friends.
And it's so fun
because we're not.
You actually think
you all like each other.
We love each other.
JAY:
That's a wrap, everybody.
Good job. Good job.
( music playing )
CARIDEE: Oh, Tyra Mail.
- Tyra Mail.
- ♪ Tyra Mail ♪
MELROSE: Tomorrow you will
meet with the judges.
Only two will continue
on in hopes of becoming
America's Next Top Model.
- Love, Tyra.
MELROSE: It's so weird going
into panel with three people.
You're like,
"Where is everybody?"
I just want
to get my name called.
EUGENA: We know
the routine already.
So we just have to go up
to the judges
and hope that they like you
and they wanna keep you.
I'm nervous.
You know, I screwed up
a lot during my commercial.
I don't know.
We'll just have to see.
( music playing )
The final three.
Looking strong and beautiful.
All right. So, let's get
started with our judges.
The first is the sexy
and noted fashion photographer,
Nigel Barker.
Runway diva coach,
extraordinaire,
J. Alexander.
And our fashion icon,
Miss Twiggy.
There are two amazing men here.
They are Victorio and Lucchino.
These are the fashion designers
that will be designing
the dresses
that the two finalists
will stomp
to the death in to become
America's Next Top Model.
All right, girls,
so you all shot
a commercial for CoverGirl.
Here it is.
Wish your lip gloss
could party all night?
Finally,
color that gets it right.
New CoverGirl
Outlast Double LipShine.
It's the first lasting
shine gloss
that goes for ten hours.
MELROSE: Five times
longer than lip gloss.
Slip on the color,
slick on the shine.
CARIDEE: And you'll
be shining a very long time.
EUGENA:
Dance, dine, have a "feasta."
Your old lip gloss?
ALL: Hasta la vista.
New from easy...
- Breezy.
- Beautiful.
ALL: CoverGirl!
TYRA: That was good.
That was really, really good.
So now it's time for
your individual evaluations.
And, Melrose, you're first.
All right. Here's your best
take from the commercial.
Slip on that color
and slick on that shine,
and you'll be shining
a very long time.
Beautiful smile.
To be able to talk
and smile like
that is the reason
why they hire you for
that kind of commercial.
( speaking in Spanish )
I heard "magnifico"
and "fresca,"
and I like those words.
TYRA: So, Melrose,
you also had an ad for CoverGirl
where you had to shoot a photo.
J.: I just wish her lips would
have spoken for the LipShine.
'Cause you look
more like this, look.
- MELROSE: Mm-hmm.
- TWIGGY: Yeah.
Right. Instead of this way.
TYRA: I have to say, Melrose,
in going through your film,
I was disappointed.
I wasn't sure if you're nervous
because it's down
to the final three,
or if you're not
a natural beauty shot girl.
- Okay.
- All right, thanks.
Up next is Eugena.
It's the first lasting
shine gloss that goes ten hours.
Five times longer
than lip gloss.
Surprise. Surprise. Surprise.
TWIGGY:
See, you have got a personality.
Where's that girl
been this entire competition?
Um, I was just nervous.
But this the most
nerve-racking thing the world
to have to do a commercial.
This was like the easiest
thing I had to do, so.
NIGEL:
Let me ask you a question.
You might smile,
but when you return back
to your regular face,
it's not really a smile,
and it's often not really there.
TYRA: Do you want this Eugena?
Do you wanna be a model?
Do you really wanna be a model?
- I do really wanna be a model.
- TYRA: All right.
J.: It's really funny,
because as she said that,
it didn't come out
like you really want it.
No, I do. That's why
I'm trying to come out
and trying to show
you guys that I can do it.
NIGEL: Beautiful.
You are smiling with your eyes.
That's something
you haven't done yet.
TWIGGY: Well, it's amazing
that this has suddenly happened.
You left it 'till the 11th hour.
J.: Which is scary, because
this makes one wonder,
will you fall back
and not keep going forward?
That's a long way to fall.
Up next is CariDee.
Dance, dine, have a "feasta."
Your old lip gloss,
hasta la vista.
You were the only girl that
said, "Dance and you dine."
You gave a little something
and you were modeling
while you were doing it.
Only thing is,
every now and then, you frown.
TWIGGY: Yeah. I think you
just did a little bit too much.
You've got to slow it down.
Oh, yeah.
TWIGGY: It's very sophisticated.
Your skin looks wonderful
and your lips
look very luscious.
J.: This is actually
how I like you.
It's kind more relaxed.
CARIDEE: I was just really
trying to relax, not be porno,
not be sexy.
I have to say that your
film was probably the best.
You blew them away with
this picture in my opinion.
NIGEL: This kind of shot's
a great shot for you.
And looking at you
in judging, too, today,
you look very much
like a model.
This is the way we should have
seen you from the beginning.
All right. So it's time
for the judges to deliberate,
to decide who the two
finalists will be.
All right, you all,
it's time to decide
who are two finalists are.
Eugena.
NIGEL: Maybe this is probably
Eugena's strongest shot to date.
TWIGGY: I mean, this is
a sensational photograph.
My worry with her
is that, for me,
there's no personality.
J.: Even when you speak
with her and you ask
a question, "Yeah."
- Do you wanna be a model?
- Yes, I do.
TYRA: Do you really
wanna be a model?
I do really wanna be a model.
"Well, I--Yeah, I want it."
NIGEL: Someone like
CariDee, on the other hand,
does have a lot of personality.
You don't know
what you're gonna get.
You don't know what
you're gonna get.
It's called the CariDee mystery.
NIGEL: If she could pull
the whole act together,
she could do a good
commercial too.
J.: But I think CariDee
pulls the whole act together,
- there will be no act.
- TYRA: Melrose.
TWIGGY: It's not my
favorite photograph of Melrose,
but over the competition,
I think she has done
consistently great photographs.
I love her passion.
I do see someone
that wants this.
Melrose is obviously
the perfectionist.
But I don't think
that she's a natural.
And someone like Eugena
doesn't have the drive,
but she has the natural talent
to take a beautiful picture.
TWIGGY: Though her earlier
photographs were terrible.
NIGEL: Three pictures,
we've all changed up on the...
No, that's true.
When I walked in this morning,
I kind of thought,
"I know," and now
I'm completely confused.
( music playing )
TYRA:
Three girls stand before me.
But I only have
two photos in my hands.
And these photos
represent the two girls
that will compete
in a beautiful fashion show
to become
America's Next Top Model.
The first name
that I'm going to call...
CariDee.
( music playing )
Oh, my gosh.
- TYRA: Congratulations.
- Thank you.
TYRA: You're still
in the running towards
becoming America's Next
Top Model.
You're a finalist.
Oh, thank you.
Congratulations.
Will Melrose and Eugena
please step forward?
I only have one photo
in my hands.
And this photo
represents the girl
that will be a finalist
and compete against
CariDee to become
America's Next Top Model.
Now, I'll only call one name,
and the girl
that I do not call
must immediately return
to your house here in Spain,
pack your belongings,
and go home.
You both stand before me
for very different reasons.
Melrose, you've
consistently taken absolutely
beautiful pictures,
but then this week comes,
the judges didn't
see and I didn't see
that girl that performed
so strongly from week to week.
And then we have you, Eugena,
a girl that started
off so roughly.
But let's fast-forward,
around three weeks ago.
We started seeing
beautiful pictures.
But the judges aren't sure
if you really want to be here,
if this is your passion.
Melrose.
Oh.
Look at this.
- Oh.
- That's not great.
- No.
- TYRA: But you have a history
with this competition
of producing fantastic pictures.
And right now,
something's happening
and making you fall apart.
- This is the end.
- Yeah.
TYRA: Congratulations.
You're still on the running
towards becoming
America's Next Top Model.
- Thank you.
- You're welcome.
You're gonna keep going and say,
"What you saw on
Top Model is not what I am.
I really, really want this."
It's okay. It's okay.
I promise,
I'll get this for you.
EUGENA: I just wished
that my performance
spoke for itself instead
of actually telling them,
but sometimes you
have to say what you mean
and how you feel.
If I didn't wanna be here,
then I wouldn't have made
it this far.
So I'm pretty disappointed.
Disappointed in myself
that I didn't explain
myself better in panel.
And those are the type of things
that can make you or break you.
In this case,
it got me sent home.
( music playing )
CARIDEE: It's really sad
to see Eugena go.
She was such a good,
kind-hearted person.
"Walk your ass
off on that runway
'cause a natural
blonde needs to win."
That's right.
Now this house feels
like just pure competition.
It is the battle
of the blondes,
but she has to go.
( music playing )
MELROSE: "When I first went
to Paris to model,
I had just graduated high school
and was just 17 years old."
- "Seventeen years old."
- Aah!
"Love, Tyra."
- Hey.
- CARIDEE: Hi.
Today, both of you girls
are shooting
for Seventeen Magazine.
Whoever wins
America's Next Top Model
has the shot they do today
on the cover of Seventeen.
So I want
to introduce you guys
to your Seventeen Magazine crew.
Come on out here, guys.
So you guys remember Atoosa,
obviously, from earlier on
in the season.
She's the editor-in-chief
of Seventeen Magazine.
Beau Quillian,
the style director of Seventeen,
and your photographer today,
George Holz.
I hope that I have taught
you guys everything
that you need to know,
because
I leave you guys today.
CARIDEE: Growing up,
I always loved taking pictures.
I love the camera.
I've always
had a passion for it.
But, you know,
I was weird-looking and plus
I had my skin disease where I
never thought I would
succeed in
the modeling industry.
ATOOSA: CariDee is more
than just a pretty face.
I feel like she's a strong girl,
she's a confident girl.
She has come out.
It's there.
My gut is like, "Melrose,
you freaked out the first week,
but you've really been
trying your best
and when there
was so much personality
questioning going on,
you still didn't lose it."
I feel like I found
myself this week again,
and I feel like I really
proved that I can do this.
ATOOSA: Melrose
has a very unique look.
She doesn't look
like just any girl.
And I think that that could
work to her advantage.
That's nice.
Some really cute stuff.
- Bye.
- Bye-bye.
( music playing )
- MELROSE: Tyra Mail.
- CARIDEE: Tyra Mail.
Tyra Mail.
Oh.
Maybe we'll see her.
"Not every couch in the modeling
business is a casting couch.
"It's time to pick your
brain to see if you have
"what it takes to be
America's Next Top Model,
- "Love Tyra."
( music playing )
- TYRA: Hi.
- Hi.
I want the winner
of America's Next Top Model
to be healthy in mind, body,
and spirit.
- This is Dr. Michelle.
- Hi.
And Dr. Michelle is a life
coach, and she actually
helps me a lot
on my talk show.
And I love Dr. Michelle.
She keeps it so real.
In the event that
you win this competition,
how do you feel like
you'll manage the stress?
I think, I can really--I
really can manage it
just because my whole life,
I've just been critiqued
and been made fun of.
I never let it stop me,
but it did take a toll
on my self-esteem.
You're so outgoing now.
Were you that way when
people were teasing you?
I've always been really
happy, and I think a lot
of my humor has taken away,
like, my sadness.
DR. MITCHELL: What's the
biggest change you've seen
in yourself
during this process?
I've really come back
into who I am.
I was trying to fit in
so much that I probably
wasn't really being myself.
What are some things
that you think
you could change about yourself?
Maybe sometimes,
the way that I see things
doesn't come off right.
What you just did was great,
which is that you acknowledged
that there's place for change.
TYRA: Well,
you have a fashion show.
- Yay.
- You're almost there.
- Thank you so much.
- TYRA: You're welcome.
( music playing )
JAY: Is this not the most
gorgeous place you could be.
- Heaven.
- This is Park Guell,
and it was designed
by the artist Gaudi.
So today, you girls are doing
your final runway show.
You girls are gonna be
ghostly brides.
- Awesome.
- JAY: Danielle,
"Dani" is here,
she's opening the show.
As the show progresses, each
walk will get more theatrical,
and for the last walk,
basically,
you guys are gonna come tearing
around the corner
like mad women.
CARIDEE: No!
Hi, Miss J.
JAY: This is all about
craziness,
back and forth to the end.
You're in your
own cuckoo crazy world.
( music playing )
MELROSE: I love
the hair and makeup.
I think this
is such a cool idea.
( music playing )
MELROSE: I'm definitely
looking at CariDee,
and I think
I can stand out stronger.
- Okay.
- Oh, don't make me cry, no.
( music playing )
CARIDEE: I haven't really
had much conversation
with Melrose because
I'm gonna kick ass.
( music playing )
Hello.
The brides of Frankenstein.
( speaking in Spanish )
You're gonna be nice
and then roar.
You know, your problem is,
you need longer steps,
leaner steps, and
your problem is nice walk,
but this just goes.
So, there you go.
Thank you, Tyra.
- Adios.
- TYRA: Adios.
Remember, keep your energy up.
This is really about
creating a scene.
MELROSE: The nerves
have definitely kicked in.
The battle of the blondes
is in full effect now.
CARIDEE: I know Melrose,
this girl isn't as strong
as she tries to put off.
This is mine.
Let's have a great show,
lots of energy.
You gotta stomp it out
and make it work.
( Gregorian chant playing )
MELROSE: This might be the
coolest thing I've ever done.
We're gonna be in this
crazy hair and makeup
and actually
get to be ghost brides.
CARIDEE:
This is the final test.
This is the last one to impress.
This is the last one
to strut your stuff.
This is the last
opportunity to show
that you can become
America's Next Top Model.
( eerie music playing )
( girls scream )
( music playing )
Whoo!
Go. Rock it, Melrose.
( music playing )
Nice.
Come on, CariDee.
Make it fierce.
( music playing )
Whoa.
Yeah!
Great job, Melrose!
JAY: Good. Are you tired?
I know, it's a long walk.
All right. This is scene two,
the diss.
Remember to stop and
stare down the other model.
Go, CariDee.
Go, Melrose.
Yes!
( fabric rips )
All I hear is...
( imitates tearing sound )
she steps on the dress
and it rips.
( music playing )
I don't know what that was,
but it was something.
MELROSE: It's not like
a little rip, it's a hole.
It's a hole.
You hold it up,
you can put
your head through it.
Whoo! That was hot.
( music playing )
- I'll be right back.
- Where is he going?
MELROSE: I was so freaked out
about the dress being ripped.,
I just wanted to run.
Cari.
Oh, my God.
She stepped on the dress.
You stepped on the dress.
CARIDEE:
Melrose gets so upset.
It was an accident.
I just wanna say sorry though.
MELROSE:
Sorry doesn't change it.
You're sorry? You're sorry?
I'm pissed, and I wanna
smack CariDee across the--
I just wanna num-chuck her.
Calm down.
This is the crazy scene.
( eerie music playing )
( woman screams )
( music playing )
TYRA: Whoo!
This is so crazy.
I just have to suck it up,
spit it out, and go
into the next walk.
Well done, J.
Now, go.
Crazy the whole time.
MELROSE: And luckily
it was a lot of screaming
and being crazy because that's
kind of a lot of the things
I was feeling.
( screams )
She's doing good.
TWIGGY:
She's really there.
Aah!
Go now.
( screaming )
Aah!
( applause )
Last looks
for the finale walk, okay?
( applause )
MELROSE: I should be
America's Next Top Model,
because with all the conditions
and the disastrous
experiences...
Thank you.
You guys are so nice.
My performance rocked.
You guys are all amazing.
CARIDEE: I just wanna make
it to the top.
I just wanna prove
it to everyone
who ever had doubted me.
Hopefully, hopefully, I win.
( music playing )
TYRA: Well, well, well,
the final two.
Who would have
known that Melrose
and CariDee would be
our two finalists?
So now it's time
to decide who's gonna be
America's Next Top Model.
Every time I hear that,
my stomach just goes...
And I'm gonna tell you
about the prizes
for the last time,
because one of you
is going to be receiving those.
The first is a contract
with one of the top
modeling agencies
in the world,
Elite Model Management,
a cover and a six-page spread
of Seventeen Magazine,
and a $100,000 contract
with CoverGirl Cosmetics.
And, of course,
you know our judges.
We know you well,
and there's another person
in this competition
that knows you just as much,
if not more, and that
is Mr. Jay Manuel,
who's the art director
of your photo shoots.
All right. So now it's time
for your individual evaluations,
and after that,
us five judges will deliberate,
and we will determine
who will be
America's Next Top Model.
So, ladies, please step forward.
So you all had a fashion
show for Victorio Lucchino.
And, Melrose, we're gonna
see your best walk first.
( music playing )
TWIGGY: I thought you
were wonderful last night.
You showed the dresses.
You looked very confident.
TYRA:
You didn't overcompensate,
you didn't go,
"I'm gonna be strong for Tyra."
It looked like a real model
on that runway.
NIGEL: In the acting segment,
I could see photograph after
photograph after photograph.
J.: And considering the dress
was a little too big for you,
I believe,
you managed to pull it through.
You managed to come through.
And it was so graceful
and so beautiful.
You looked like you were
floating, it was wonderful.
TYRA: All right.
So, CariDee, you were in
the fashion show as well.
J.: You need
to just keep it pretty,
simple, and strong.
NIGEL: You lose yourself.
When you walk in just
for judging, if you could walk
like that on the runway,
you'd have a better walk.
TYRA: To me,
it looked like you were holding
your breath the whole time.
- I was just gonna say that.
- TYRA: It looked like this.
NIGEL: And then, of course,
we have the theatrical runway.
( screams )
NIGEL: You took it to
a level where it was all
theatrics and no modeling.
TYRA: You were holding
the dress up where we can never
see what the dress was,
but you're
still selling a dress.
And this is what
you did down the runway.
TWIGGY: What you have
naturally is so wonderful.
JAY: You need to trust
in your beauty.
We've talked about this,
and even standing right now,
you're taking very harsh
criticism for us,
and you're handling this,
which I think
is a higher pressure
situation, much better than
you handled that show.
TYRA: This judging is not
just based on the final runway,
but your overall performance
in the competition.
And we're going
to go through some of those
photo shoots right now.
The first one we're gonna
look at is your supermodel
stereotypes photo shoot.
CariDee you were a dumb model
reading a book upside down.
NIGEL: CariDee this shot
was a stunning shot for you.
Beautiful,
the body language, the face.
TYRA: Melrose, you were a model
that would not get out
of bed for less than
$10,000 a day.
It's not quite there, is it?
You've done better.
JAY: Melrose, between
the attitude, the drama,
I honestly thought that week,
you were gone.
TYRA: For your celebrity
couple photo shoot.
Melrose, you were
Don and Melania Trump.
And CariDee,
you were Brad and Angelina.
JAY: This day, both of you
girls exceled by far
in front of the rest
of competition for me.
TYRA: Then you posed for romance
novel covers with Fabio.
TWIGGY: CariDee, it was the
first time I had seen you
looking very gentle,
very vulnerable,
because we'd only seen
your bubbly side.
JAY: Melrose, that day,
you were doing something
that Tyra does very well.
She could do something
very sexy in a photo
without it ever
looking raunchy.
TYRA: The same week,
I photographed you
with my little amateur
photography but...
That was fun.
J.: They're great pictures
but I think, CariDee,
yours is a bit stronger.
The body language,
the expression in the eyes
- was perfect.
- TYRA: Melrose.
NIGEL: There just isn't enough
life in the picture for me.
You put too much thought
into the character.
NIGEL: This is
where I began to see,
you were all about being
a perfectionist.
Whether you had
the natural ability or not
is what was in question.
TYRA: All right.
So you all had to be matadors
with Nigel Barker.
J.: Miss CariDee,
it's no bull that your picture
was quite strong.
This is one of my favorite
shots of the entire thing.
JAY: This is a little
reminiscent of the CariDee
we met in casting with
that garter up on her leg.
I've been trying really
to tone down the sex.
TYRA: And you don't even
have a big booty
and breasts like I do,
but I have to think, like,
"Take it away."
Do things to take
it totally away,
because if not, I will look
like I'm in a men's magazine.
- Absolutely.
- TYRA: Melrose.
JAY: I really think you
could have done much better.
I think you look forced here.
NIGEL: What you didn't
do was to make it your own.
TYRA: And the last photo shoot
is your CoverGirl photo shoot.
TWIGGY: I think they're
both very beautiful photos,
but I think the CariDee one
jumps out a bit more.
NIGEL: CariDee,
you found light in this shot.
J.: CariDee,
I think it's beautiful.
I do love the neck extension.
Melrose, I thought you were
a bit tight around the mouth.
NIGEL: A little plain
in the expression.
TYRA: There are two things
in this competition
that are
the most important things.
One is this
CoverGirl photo shoot
and one is your fashion show.
In the CoverGirl photo shoot,
CariDee, you excelled.
That could be an ad right now.
Melrose, that doesn't look
like an ad to me.
Then you go to the fashion show.
In the fashion show, Melrose,
you excelled.
That is a model working
on the runway, and, CariDee,
your performance would never
book a fashion show.
And, of course, your body
of work is important, too,
but like school, there's
all the tests that you do,
and then there's
that final exam.
So we have a lot to think about.
And it's time for us
to deliberate.
And when I call you back,
I'll announce which one
of you will be
America's Next Top Model.
( music playing )
TYRA: We've got CariDee,
and we've got Melrose,
and we have to decide
which one of them
is going to be
America's Next Top Model.
We got two blondes,
we got two completely
different girls, though.
Melrose takes
beautiful pictures.
She's a great model,
but Melrose to me
doesn't have the same
"wow" factor as CariDee.
Because she knows everything,
it's been studied.
That factor,
you know, it all is useful,
but you've got to know
how to turn it off.
TYRA: I know that she
has a history of the girls
not really liking her.
She has excelled
in this competition,
her pictures are beautiful.
Maybe that's jealousy.
We're chastising Melrose
for the thing that we ask
from all these girls
which is intelligence,
knowledge of this industry.
Yes. Okay.
Melrose has the knowledge,
but the passion,
I only see in CariDee.
TWIGGY: I love CariDee.
She makes me laugh,
but she is a bit
of a loose cannon.
Melrose was amazing
on that runway last night.
CariDee was...
J.: CariDee was a bit busted.
- I mean, she...
- TWIGGY: A bit?
J.: She was a bit broke down.
Let's think
of this business, guys.
The fashion industry
loves extremes.
CariDee, she's an extreme,
and there are designers
out there who would say
"She is cuckoo crazy nuts,
and I want that for my show."
She becomes a star.
TYRA: But would they love this?
She was the runaway
bride of Chucky.
TYRA: So we got
two different girls.
We have a girl that knows
her fashion,
is a strong girl.
I'm not sure
if she's intimidating
or not likeable.
Then we have another girl,
who has a pureness
and a lightness,
also takes amazing pictures,
but we're not sure
if she's the most kind of...
- Stable.
- ...stable, you know,
She's
kind of unpredictable.
- She's a loose cannon.
- Unpredictable.
But is unpredictable
a bad thing?
JAY: I think everyone
at this table
is unpredictable,
and we're sitting here.
I'm not unpredictable, child.
You know, I'm gonna have
a hair weave,
a bunch of makeup on,
and a dress,
that's cinched at my waist.
( music playing )
TYRA: The final two.
This is not easy.
Both of you
have amazing strengths
and both of you
have some weaknesses.
What does this
competition meant to you?
I love this industry.
I love--I love modeling.
I love it so much,
and for, you know,
a part of my life,
I thought
I could never do it,
and now I got the chance,
and you guys believed in me.
It's amazing. Thank you.
Don't make me cry.
God, I'm a sap.
I've come a long way
in understanding,
not just myself, but other
models too in this competition,
and it's a complete--
It's a complete shocker
standing up here.
I feel like I'm having
an out-of-body experience.
I'm just--I'm
just happy to be here.
Well, the judges have
deliberated long and hard.
And America's Next Top
Model is...
( music playing )
- CariDee.
- ( sobbing ) Oh, my God.
( music playing )
Where's my alarm clock?
I need to wake up.
MELROSE: I'm pissed.
I've put my heart
and soul into this,
and it wasn't enough,
and I got called a bitch
the whole way through it,
and it sucks,
and I feel really misunderstood,
and I'm sad.
Come here.
Be proud of yourself.
You did a really,
really, really good.
It's just bum city right now.
Thank you.
Do the ugly
fashion show face.
Rrrr!
I don't ever wanna see that
face ever, ever again.
CARIDEE: Aah!
Oh, my God.
I won.
I won. I did it.
I'm a CoverGirl model,
I'm gonna be on the cover
of Seventeen Magazine.
I'm so excited.
You know, my dream
is always to be a model
and always to be in
the modeling industry, and,
you know, having psoriasis
always prohibited me.
I had those kids in junior
high who would make fun of me,
and always wanted to model
and always couldn't,
because I had this crazy
skin disease
that I couldn't control.
I'm America's
Next Top Model, baby!
Yes.
( music playing )
TYRA: Stay tuned
for a look at CariDee's
winning photo shoot with me.
We look like
we're going to prom.
- We are.
- Sparkles.
TYRA: CariDee is real.
What you see is what you get.
She's had some
difficulties in her past,
and she's come through,
and she's come through strong.
She really is a role model.
She's a good girl.
( music playing )
♪ It's time to make it hot ♪
♪ You know that we don't stop ♪
♪ And when you get it hot ♪
♪ You got to be on top ♪
♪ Na na na na na na,
na na na na ♪
♪ You wanna be on top? ♪
♪ Na na na na na na,
na na na na ♪
♪ You wanna be on top? ♪